Anyone who knows me
knows that I love to talk.
I'm a chatterbox, just ask anyone.
I like to think that I'm pretty good
at building rapport with my clients.
And having spent just under a decade
working as a lawyer,
I tell you, this is one skill
that really came in handy.
Now, I remember this one
interstate client in particular.
We got on like a house on fire.
We spent months corresponding over email
and chatting over the phone.
And then the day finally came
when we would meet face to face.
So I walk into the meeting room,
and there she is.
I say hello,
and she kind of gives me this odd look.
And she says,
"Oh, you must work for Mariam."
(Audience murmurs)
And I'm thinking, "What does she mean?"
And then it dawns on me.
She must think
I'm the legal secretary
or the assistant perhaps.
Not that there's anything
wrong with having those jobs.
But it seems that in her mind,
the voice that she's heard
on the phone all these months
doesn't seem to correspond
to the person standing in front of her.
Rather unconvincingly
at that point, I say,
"No, I am Mariam."
And then I start to doubt myself.
And all those months of rapport building
just goes down the drain at that point
as I start again from scratch
to win her over.
I do, of course, eventually win her over,
but it was a lot of time and effort wasted
and ultimately, yet another hit
to my confidence.
And the thing is,
I have other experiences like that one.
And I know plenty
of other folks who do too.
So today I want to reflect
on how stereotyping,
unconscious bias and societal privilege
operates in such a way
that creates an unequal playing field
for diverse minority groups.
Now, let us start with privilege.
Privilege is basically unearned advantage.
Hey, what the hell, we really
didn't do much to earn it.
It's basically access to
or enjoying rights
because you belong
to a particular identity.
You're part of a club.
And here's the thing.
I am owning up to mine.
I am privileged.
Hey, and if you could afford
the ticket price,
you probably are too.
(Laughter)
And here's the thing.
Privilege is relative,
and it’s ultimately subjective.
And those who have the most amounts of it,
they’re probably not
entirely conscious of it.
Because for the most part,
and as they say, privilege is largely
invisible to those who have it.
Now, I work as a diversity
and inclusion consultant,
so I do spend a hell of a lot of my day
thinking about these concepts.
Think about this.
Whose faces do you see
reflected back at you
on your television screens?
Who holds the top positions
in the top ranks of society?
Now, except for the few
examples here or there,
notice the general lack
of cultural diversity?
Now, of course,
the photos that you're seeing up there
are some of our top CEOs,
chancellors of universities,
federal cabinet and TV
personalities in particular.
Now, what we're actually
exposed to every day
feeds the assumptions
that we make about people.
We all tend to possess
a strong tendency towards people
who physically resemble ourselves.
It's called affinity bias.
Now experiments have shown us
that the brain actually categorizes
by race in less than 100 milliseconds.
Now, according to Nobel Peace Prize
recipient neuroscientist Eric Kandel,
he argues that up to 90 percent
of the brain's behavior
is actually unconscious.
So these little shortcuts
that the brain makes,
these little implicit
associations, these biases,
for the most part,
they are done unconsciously.
And here's the thing.
Inherent societal privilege
means that some of us
are given a head start
in what I like to call the race of life.
And it's because of that head start,
not just because we worked
extra, extra hard,
that they'll always be miles ahead,
even if all the participants
are running at the same speed
and with the same ability.
So that's code for the same
amount to merits,
or in this case,
running the same distance.
Now, it's well documented
that women of minority groups
face even greater hurdles,
as you can see.
They face both social and institutional
barriers to full equality,
not just because they're chicks,
but because of things such as race,
religion, sexuality or disability.
They basically have a double whammy.
And that concept is referred to
as intersectionality.
Now, as an Australian woman
who's originally from Afghanistan
and a Muslim,
I get the triple whammy.
I get sexism, I get racism,
and I get Islamophobia.
You know, some people boast
about having a fan base.
Well, ladies and gentlemen,
I have a troll base.
(Laughter)
Such a clever bunch,
they've totally mastered the art
of intersectional insults.
That's not easy to do.
Now, if only I had a dollar
for every time someone said,
"But all appointment should be on merit."
Well, of course they should be.
But here's the thing.
Are we assuming
that the existing status quo
is somehow based entirely on merit?
I'm not convinced that it is.
But hey, don't take my word for it.
Plenty of other people think that, too.
Now, I recall a conversation
I was having with two senior managers.
It was about corporate Australia’s shift
to start focusing on cultural diversity
within its leadership ranks,
now that we're doing better
around gender diversity.
One of them was a woman
of Asian-Australian heritage
and she was a former colleague of mine.
The other, a colleague of hers,
a man of Anglo-Celtic origin.
Now it's in the context of this discussion
in which he turns to her,
the Asian-Australian woman, and says,
"There you go.
Another leg up for people like you."
Now she's shocked
because they're colleagues,
so she says nothing.
But I can't stay silent.
(Laughter)
I literally put hand out like this.
Got up from my pedestal and I said,
"When you extend a hand
to a group of people,
who, for far too long, have been
effectively walking in the gutter
while others comfortably
stroll the streets,
that ain't no leg up.
That certainly is not a handout,
that's simply leveling the playing field."
Now, studies have shown us
that to simply obtain
the same number of interviews
as someone with an Anglo-Saxon
sounding name,
candidates from Indigenous, Middle Eastern
and Asian-sounding names
have to submit a ridiculous amount
of more applications.
So in this case, when compared
to Lisa and Andrew,
and these are the real names
used in the study,
Nadine and Hassan have to submit
64 percent more applications,
while Ming and Hong have to submit
68 percent more applications.
Guys, we're be talking about getting
a callback to secure an interview.
We're not even talking
about the kind of biases that will kick in
once you're actually
at the interviewing table.
Now, I can't tell you the number
of crappy dad jokes I've had to make
to make interviewers feel comfortable
when they first meet me
early on in my career.
Thanks for laughing.
(Laughter)
Now, despite the fact
that up to 40 percent of Australians
have at least one parent born overseas,
no doubt that's probably
true of this arena,
that general diversity is not reflected
in the top ranks of society.
Now, of course, I'm not suggesting
there's anything wrong with this,
assuming it is truly based
on a meritocracy.
And for culturally diverse women like me,
well, you know that glass ceiling?
It's double glazed for people like me.
And that's why I've got heels like this,
to be able to crack through it.
Only a tiny percentage of ASX directors
are culturally diverse women.
At a CEO level, it is even worse.
So think about all those stats
that I've been telling you about,
all those biases that we know about.
What message does this send
to a generation of top HSC graduates
who are culturally diverse?
I'm hoping that by this point,
some of you are convinced
on the moral case
for why change is required
to level that damn playing field.
But then there'll be others
who won't be convinced
unless we show them the dollar figures.
Hey, don't worry, I've got it covered.
There is a thing
called the diversity dividend,
that gender diverse companies
are 15 percent more likely
to outperform their industry average,
while culturally diverse companies,
they're 35 percent more likely
to outperform theirs.
So diversity brings with it
a competitive advantage.
And here's the thing,
anyone at this point who's thinking,
"Oh, she means tokenistic,
visible diversity."
No.
I'm not asking you to whack on photos
of people that look like me
onto your website and tick a box.
(Laughter)
Although that might be nice.
No, that's not what I'm talking about.
Real diversity brings about
diversity of perspective,
diversity of views
and diversity of thought.
Ultimately, and of course,
the inevitable flow-on effect
is that Australian businesses
will be able to better reflect
and understand the needs
of a multicultural Australia
who is ultimately their customer base.
So with everything I've said,
I want us to pause at this point.
And I'm going to ask each of you
to please stand.
Yes, please stand.
If you can't stand,
then I'll ask you to please
raise one hand instead.
And you get to stretch your legs.
No, we're not doing a yoga lesson.
OK.
I'm going to ask you
a series of questions.
If the answer to the question is yes,
I want you to remain standing
or with your hand up.
If the answer to the question is no,
then I want you to take a seat
and the rest of the questions
will be directed at those people
who are still standing.
Please be as honest as you can.
Question one.
Did you have a job during high school?
If yes, keep standing,
if no, please take your seat.
I quite like the power of ordering
all 4,000 of you to do things.
(Laughter)
This is cool.
Question two.
Have you been discriminated against,
vilified or abused because of something
you cannot change about yourself?
And let's watch the room
as we start to see people sit.
Question three.
At some point in your life,
you have felt like you've been
one of the few or the only persons
of your gender, race, faith,
sexual orientation or disability
in a room, in an educational
or professional setting?
And final question.
Have you attended a public school
for the majority of your education?
Whoa.
(Laughter)
Knew that would get a few of us.
OK.
Thank you for being brave enough
to participate by the way.
If I answered those questions,
I would be standing at this point
with those of you that are still standing
in the arena.
I want us to reflect
on our own levels of privilege
and what that means for each of us.
I want you to reflect
on who's standing and who's sitting
without making anyone
feeling uncomfortable.
But let's think about that.
Thank you for being brave
and please take a seat now.
(Applause)
Thank you.
I want to tell you this.
There's never been a more important time
for us to be conscious of our unconscious
biases and societal privileges.
You know, when you're driving and you know
you've got a blind spot back here,
you know it exists, but you can't see it.
But you make a concerted effort
to turn your head each and every time
to look and to adjust.
It's not enough to know
that we've got these biases
and that we have
these levels of privilege.
You've got to do something about it.
We're living in an era
where divisive politics
has successfully otherized
diverse minority groups
and normalized xenophobia against them.
We're constantly reading
derogatory headlines
about diverse minority groups.
And what's worse is some of these remarks
are made by our elected officials.
Now, I believe that when you
excuse bigotry in words,
you lay the framework
to give bigotry in action a free pass.
We know that we have an urgent issue
of disenfranchisement amongst the youth,
particularly those of diverse backgrounds.
We want them to reach for the stars.
But the thing is, you can't aspire
to be someone that you can't see.
You can't address inequality equally.
You can't.
This is why I believe targets
are required across industries
where diversity of this kind is lacking.
Now, why, you ask, why targets?
Because the definition of insanity
is doing the same thing
over and over again
and expecting different results.
(Applause)
Thank you.
The existing status quo has not allowed us
to reach a true meritocracy.
So we need additional measures
to give us a bit of a nudge.
Because let’s face it:
what gets measured ultimately gets done.
Thank you very much, ladies and gentlemen.
(Applause)